[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
of Kos and today we have the mad Titan
Thanos now you guys are used to this
movie Thanos who looks like a little
like a little Greek for something the
tennis you're gonna see today's
sideshows Thanos and and I love this
piece when it first came up I couldn't
pre-order it fast enough because it
reminded me of Jim starlings first work
when I sword like I'm a big proponent of
Adam warlock Captain Marvel Silver
Surfer the cosmic entities within the
Marvel Universe and he represented
panels representative death destruction
as you learn more about the mad Titan as
the years go on
you realize his exact goal and it was
just to please lady death now none of
this stuff has come across in the movies
then they actually didn't touch on this
his motivations in the movies is totally
different than his motivations in the
comic book his motivations in the comic
book is just to kill as much people as
possible to please lady death
now the book started off with him first
going after the Cosmic Cube and you guys
call it the tesseract because this is
what you've been taught and it's a
MacGuffin inside the comic books it's an
artifact of immense power the Cosmic
Cube it is when it came to the Marvel
Universe the MCU that you guys used to
win the movies they call it the
tesseract then they made it an infinity
gem well there's not a gem
it's a storm and the movies this is the
difference in the comic books they call
infinity gems and movies that call
Infinity stones so as they went on from
the first thinking's of and penciling 's
of Thanos that I saw when he was
fighting Adam warlock and all of those
great stories they decided to bring them
back later on when they brought him back
later on it was a book called the Thanos
quest and in that book he was on a quest
to find all these infinity gems and
elders of the universe had him he went
and he collected them he outsmarted them
he tricked him maybe out of brute force
but you learned who tano's was and how
diabolical he was in this book called
Thanos quest
then came the Infinity Gauntlet when you
got there finiti gauntlet that's after
he assembled all the gems and he made
the gauntlet now the gauntlet was always
an extension of the actual gauntlet that
he had it wasn't a special gauntlet it
always was one that was off his costume
and he put the gems inside
now he goes on and the heroes have to
stop him an affinity war
then came the infinity crusade then came
a couple of other books about Thanos but
what Marvel found out was that this guy
was probably one of the most magnetizing
villains that they had his more
diabolical than Magneto more sinister
than Doctor Doom but Marvel kind of
rectified that because they always
wanted doomed to be that big bad that
unstoppable evil villain but we're
talking about Daniels here we're talking
about the mad Titan we're talking about
the guy that was able to assemble this
this Infinity Gauntlet I got this
Infinity Gauntlet its sideshow I guess
it's from what their toe line is called
hot toys I picked this up just to
display it I also have a prop replica
coming but that's a beautiful toy that
you can get and lights up I think see
all the gems is lighting up they light
up officially you see that hundred
dollars and get it display it
show your fanboy isn't it nerd out on it
it's nice
but this statue level of detail sideshow
of course took their liberties with
Thanos his armor but his robust nature
his muscles his face is all jim Starlin
jim Starlin has a very good writers and
anchors style that ad style it was it
was beautiful seventies and eighties
style so to see this character to come
to life and you know that end game and
infinity war has come to the big screen
and a lot of the people that don't you
know naturally buy comic books can share
in this villain it just makes me so
happy so everybody go out go see endgame
this statue I already had it unboxed
this is one of my best statues I saved
it I put the music up and I really
wanted you guys to see the statue and
all this glory please stick around check
out all the pictures and make sure that
you like follow subscribe iron Lords
podcast and also go to Lords of gaming
dotnet where we have tons of opinion
pieces movie reviews an endgame right a
lot of other video game related news as
III slowly creeps up upon us
I want you guys to stick where we are so
you can get all the latest news and all
the facts not fiction also tune in to
the last word every Friday at 9:00 a.m.
standard Eastern Time with loyal kognito
and loading boxes for all that looter
shooter greatness the division - destiny
- boy oh boy
so without further ado I give you
sideshows mad Titan Thanos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]